hello and welcome to this video playing
a river Boca yeah I've had some he 45s
against him so going to switch it a
little bit and see what happens if I get
an idea three should be benefits to
having broader opening repertoire
I had actually good positions in the
e-40 five games I had was winning
positions that I remember those two
games had that was okay that was an OK
game and that was a completely winning
game that I spoiled okay so let's see
what we get here against the river Boca
he and has played this closed setup from
the modern defense here White has a
substantial strategic threat of playing
g4 black basically has to play a 5 now
well yeah it is just f5 right there's no
other move yeah he has to has to do this
yeah I have a couple of interesting
ideas one is to play g4 which is a funny
idea I mean it's me it's maybe not the
best move that taking is probably the
best but it's just a funny move that I
like to play no black now can play a
form after which we get a totally closed
position on the kingside or you can take
and normally will take on g4 after which
I go Knight h2 and regain the pawn and
then we have a yeah somewhat uncommon
situation there with the F file open
black quite often will then try to use
their Foursquare I think black should
take on G form after f4 I think why this
is at least a bit better you know that's
I think the right choice a very
interesting motif that is very common
here is that black after castling short
will in many cases put a hook on to f4
potentially and offering an exchange
sacrifice and it's not easy for y to
ever take that exchange because then the
bishop would be very active like rook FA
drew care for in such a situation
ok that's interesting black is fighting
here with this move for the control over
you for so I'm sorry over G fo yeah take
now I mean that cannot be a bad end game
the question is how to play it this is
probably going to be fine nevertheless
what wrong wording no matter what let's
say that should always be quite quite
useful to put the King on to you to an
to cover the pawn an interesting
question is however what what is he
doing that
I was thinking Knight f6 is kind of
normal okay
I wonder what to do with the night I was
thinking night to e3 to f5 but obviously
that's not going to happen
I wonder yeah and c5 may use this
opportunity I think taking taking looks
wrong if I get like D takes Bishop takes
and if I get to take on his 7 I would be
pretty pretty bad for black then then I
would have night d1 III f5y takes Bishop
takes if we trade this okay that is
interesting because now I get the Knight
to c4 very quickly yeah okay or this
move or this move okay Ruby see one
yeah no I could take on c8 because I
will get the the fork after that all
right it's going to it's going to be a
bit better for Wyatt that's not really
really the question can also play Knight
b6 or go back let's earn that that's
that's a decision that is interesting
and would require a little bit more
consideration like any tournament game I
would think about this quite intensely
because rook takes the edge rates a lot
of stuff which is not so logical with
the space advantage but the remaining
configuration is going to be of the type
that I will be able to press this
forever and ever
yeah come on let's do it I've spent too
much time to do something else now
almost okay you could take on a four
it's not entirely ridiculous this is
what I meant with a position that you
can never lose
kingi three years was also interesting
net that was better probably was just
better I tried to invade on f5 and can
try to put it on to f6 but the king the
bet bishop bishop the aide is on the
cards
okay yeah I'll get there you cannot play
Bishop e7 let's just lose this oops why
doesn't that lose my just lose
and now he has to give up the opposition
and I will either do IH pawn until
Dooley resigned yeah well I want to have
a look there this game that was was
interesting yeah here this line with 97
and 97 what can tackle in many ways h4
is one of them is probably the most
direct way of playing and really trying
to make use of the fact that black has
not put the night here which would ya
like in a similar position if you put
this here h4 would be pretty ridiculous
I mean that's not a threat and here h5
is something that black yeah it's
difficult to ignore it completely we
cost upon arriving on h5 would be just
very inconvenient
so you went h6 is what most people play
I went h5 g 5 and d5 yeah now this is
this is funny I think really f5 is
almost mandatory what the engine and now
the engine gets there and it this is
this is nice you know that the engine
has has this worked out let's say and
move like whatever let's do this yeah
it's punished by G form and then black
is in that clamp position on the
kingside you will never ever get
anywhere you can attack this but okay I
have it covered
then f3 and on the kingside nothing ever
happens the bishop stays a bad piece and
why it will slowly I can expand on the
Queen side and yeah it'd be a lot better
and in some in some sense this is
strategically almost winning for white
it's not you know mathematically a
winner but it's very very good and you
should score overwhelmingly from such
position ok f5 is better and normally I
think you take this is a stronger
movement I have a soft spot for this
idea somehow I think it's a funny way to
play ok f4 is a different story than
before because like here the points on
f7 and here it's on f4 so this is in
comparison a lot better for black still
white is going to be better because you
still have the queenside play and ok the
pawn is better on f4 then f7 but it
doesn't really change much in terms of
the queenside and black is still not
getting any attack the side of the board
is closed what why does not have here
are those squares iam at mostly for
Knights that would be nicely positioned
but yeah I still think this is services
right he played this correctly I have
six and then you take him you can also
take immediately I have three I thought
help was also looking fine at this part
of this position anyway control g4 and
so on and now Knight she ate that
regrouping I was just surprised that
after this he put the knight back on
three seven that that really surprised
me
of course you can argue if you put the
knight on to have six what exactly is
that doing hmm not the same maybe he was
also afraid that if he plays the nature
of six that this would be too strong
maybe you know but he white is more
confluent I mean it's just not it's not
up for debate c5 and in 60 mm maybe a
success or so it's questionable the
engine wants to play Knight a4
immediately that's interesting and then
we'll see one and before
hmm interesting
it gives white a really really huge
advantage Jim make one point something I
mean yeah I mean I see the point if you
if you can double behind your on the C
file and I mean that's going to look
terrible
maybe this is releasing the tension a
bit early I mean I'm still better you
know be five I think probably
objectively speaking mmm yeah I mean
okay
93 stronger that is what I suspected but
then I had summarize spent too much time
and then either okay let's let's do this
because the the resulting position here
is something that you can just play like
on the increment because it's so simple
to play here you can also play King g3
which is probably also a bit stronger
yeah and you you don't quite know after
this what you do
look f1 doesn't really feel like a
solution and kingi - it's just a
repetition yeah well I was thinking this
is this is the again the kind of ending
that you can play without much effort
and here this is already winning here
because I get this invasion on the
kingside so he should probably take
himself and then yeah try to try to
defend this in a better way the question
is if the King warp to g4 is even
remotely promising here probably not if
the king is on g4 and black gets King f6
in yeah that is the city's just saving
him there is no no idea left
to that in the game the issue was simply
it was too late to hand off my
membership coming in but him that
shouldn't be the case for example if we
let's say cannot say here and I would
actually go over to the here I don't
think I can improve my position from
here black just stays now and I mean I
cannot do anything on the queenside he
would just sit he covers this one he
covers the entry square that's probably
just mister draw probably I can try to
go over to the Queen side and play a
four and this is probably in comparison
here more promising so here I would
probably rather play like you him and
then some stuff on the Queen side there
is probably a better chance even though
again the likelihood of a draw is quite
high I mostly went for this because of
the simplicity when the time was a
little bit low and in the game it was
just too late
it was too late him now I'm getting the
Sun and in the final position sure the
engine might even display made yeah
basically a plus 54 yeah after after any
King move here or here I'm going to
enter and win the crucial pawn that's an
easy one yeah okay guys thanks for
watching